dans la continuité de leurs actions de
sensibilisation la sécurité routière les
membres du bureau des quatre commissions
du conseil départemental des jeunes se
sont essayés à la pratique du deux roues
c'est à la montagne avec l'association
azotyzone qu'ils ont piloté des motos de
trial à ma volonté a toujours été
d'apporter un complément
au niveau sécurité routière à ce qu'ils
pratiquent déjà le bsr dans le collège
et moi je voulais apporter le complément
pratique pour que les jeunes s'initient
tôt la pratique du deux roues dans les
établissements scolaires afin de leur
donner un bagage pour qu'à 14 ans et
puisse aller en sécurité sur la route
je considère que
cette pratique doit s'entraîner très tôt
nous quinzaine de jeunes soutenus dans
leur action par des motards de la police
apprennent la conduite d'un deux roues
sur cette piste après avoir commencé les
manières l'équilibré voir comment ça se
passe d'accord c'est une formation
importante pour des collégiens comme toi
pouvais je pense pas non plus connus on
passe le bc avoir une action ce tirage
parce que c'est ça l'essentiel c'est
vraiment juste pour sensibiliser pour
nous sensibiliser justement sur ça peut
être dangereux
voilà c'est on est on est sur des motos
par exemple moi qui avais jamais fait de
pratiques de deux roues maintenant
j'apprends pas mal de choses sur comment
s'y prendre et c'est toujours super
intéressant on pourra être après les
messagers pour nos camarades des
ambassadeurs raisonnable pour véhiculer
la bonne parole
une première action qui permettra
peut-être d'intégrer ces nouveaux
ateliers pratiques de sécurité routière
dans les collèges du département